it's good to see you really enjoyed the
rise I wondered about who was the
biggest prankster or jokester on set
because you have a scene Ewan with
Matthew Matthew Louis's I want your
co-stars in a film where you end up
stealing one of his jokes don't you so
he was the biggest prank storge concepts
Jerez did you deny this or you I have
known it is prankster I don't know I
think we all just kind of a lot of the
pranks we did was just kind of verbal
pranks sorry man verbal pranks and they
used a lot of that it's the
improvisation kind of on camera which
was I was really pleased yes so how much
of it was kind of scripted and how much
was it that improv it does have a very
natural feel about it the whole film
doesn't it yeah I think the script is it
was a very stylistic in the way it was
written and I think it really comes
across nicely on-screen the way that
it's well the way that's been delivered
I think and then the DM we did a little
bit of improvisation but just sort of
massing rounders to the top top and
tales of scenes and stuff to get into it
and but I think yeah I mean the script
great like I don't think when you have
something that's good you don't try and
change it too much and yeah and also
because we well apart from Matthew we
were all doing and Yorkshire accents
although Matthews was terrible
and yeah so it was it was important that
we got that kind of field and the feel
of these I think we all got on really
well and like we already respect each
other and as actors so we kind of there
was a really great sort of team feel to
this film and I really enjoyed it for
that yeah that chemistry I think really
comes across and on the screen I think
it really does yeah
massive laughter and I think like it
once said it was very much the top and
tail of the scene I agree with that
completely because you don't want to
kind of you know poison it but then at
the end of it you just want to add to it
and be creative with that
and yeah the chemistry was fantastic but
it was really nice because although I
think we're relatively young cast it one
his experience Matthew is his experience
Luke with his experience it was really
nice although we were young it felt like
kind of we all kind of just had ideas
and brought them it was a real
collaboration and it worked no one was
trying to kind of overplay Chavez
promise or anything it just fit really
well and that was that was lovely to be
apart
that was a real pleasure and a joy
really now of course it's a it's a heist
movie there's a heist element to but
it's also very much about the friendship
between these guys isn't it well I made
me think what your kind of favorite both
heist movies on the booty movies as well
you've seen over the years well um
there's so many mm meaning you've got
the kind of what I think why this film
is good is because what they're actually
trying to achieve isn't really that much
in comparison to your Ocean's eleven
type fight but to them in their world
it's it's everything so I mean I'm not
answering your question at all but I'm
doing a very politician eating know
using my hands as much like like [ __ ] um
ya know it's kind of yeah I think um
it's it's got it's got its own sort of
swing on it and it's um it's a really
original way of writing and directing
and Robinson such a fantastic job and
and still badly photographing it is done
a great job and I think um it stands up
on its own in its own kind of highs film
because it's about I think it's
something that everyone can kind of
relate to um I don't know if I said
anything if you have yet yeah you did
you're saying everyone can relate to me
so he's got your typical highs film in
that sense yeah I totally agree with its
kind of you know it's a great down to
earth aspects on that could be four lads
anyway thank gosh you know you know we
could do that and it's funny because I
never saw it as a heist film when I read
it I didn't and it towards the end you
see that book and again I think Matthew
said in an earlier interview it was
about the four lads and
and the highest thing is it's just kind
of the bit at the end really buddy films
stand by me I think I was you know I
reminded me of a Detroit Rock City as
well
do you know Edna fell on film which grew
I really liked going on and there's a
lot of that banter in that film is
brilliant I've listened how much that
improvised heist films wise I don't know
who having what what class as a heist
film would worst Luke the say in the
Shawshank Redemption eyes though you
know I don't know Matthew said The
Italian Job then you got Ocean's eleven
you know definitely stands up there with
them definitely I like the fact that is
different it was the usual suspect
element in Canada detective room as well
and all that and you know see what what
room wanted to do and and it was nice
scene from the page there's free films
that the film you read the film you
shoot and the film you edit a director
and I think the film I read came into
the film that was shot on the film that
was edited was out I was even more
pleased than the film was shot which is
that's good yeah that's really good to
him now of course there's this scene in
the film where you are you and
practicing with a crossbow and Jarrell
is helping you and it made me wonder
because in another show me know you were
play well for Game of Thrones your
character Ramsay is a skilled Archer now
how much of the skills and you take from
that to the crossbow and did you fear
for your life Darren it's the way I lost
yeah I mean the reality of filming is
that Jared's not even there it's gonna
mad
yeah I don't know I'm a very skilled
Archer and and sometimes I worry myself
how good how good you own how you keep
them in line on the fence
yeah like threat threatened with him and
Daddy yeah lunch he'd always gone ask
you one or of it yeah and I'd say and
why say comes boy Oh Robert yeah I catch
catch everyone in lunch you know cook it
on a on a fire on a spit and yeah titty
bits like that
talking of lunch how long was it before
you ate a sausage after that scene in
Game of Thrones I was a while it was a
while yeah I a lot of sausages ouais
yeah but you know I like sausages don't
get me wrong
and I'm and farmers particularly
pigs um but I'm you know right it would
know I'd be here
no no I owe it was a while yeah I didn't
have to have lunch or breakfast that day
or dinner you what was your reaction
when you saw the red wedding on the
screen
ah well when I read it I was gutted cuz
Robb Stark was kind of a favorite of
mine um and and then seeing it was even
worse I was so so upset it's like you're
not allowed to do that
Matt I've and and yeah the whole thing
was horrific
but was my daddy's a bad man and what do
you think ramsay would make it the red
wedding if he'd seen it and do you think
he's learnt any tips on Walder Frey or
I'm timing Lannister oh yeah well he's
learnt most of his tips from his dad I
think or he makes him up as he goes
along and I think he'd really have
enjoyed that wedding everybody's kind of
wedding
you